my name is Rabbi David Rosen and I am
one of the presidents of the World
Conference of religions for peace and I
actually think that the whole question
of the relationship between religion and
civil society is one of the critical
questions that is not really widely
addressed people do refer to it because
of a concern that traditional structures
could as it were being competition with
you and with new ideas and new
initiatives and I understand that
concern and therefore people are
referring to it but nobody is actually
suggesting ways in which one can advance
I think it's critically important that
young people especially the new spirit
and a new hope in the Middle East
engages the traditional structures
because i think that the mosques and the
churches and sometimes there are
synagogues as well other delivery
systems that can help not only in terms
of giving if you like the values and the
support the moral support to the Arab
Awakening and to the desire for new
empowerment but also to make this
connection between identity the
traditional roots of people's identity
and therefore and their aspirations for
the future and the churches and the
synagogues are not as significant as the
mosques but they are all very
significant than the Masters especially
our delivery systems for young people
and therefore there needs to be a
conversation between the Imams and other
religious leaders and the communities as
to how to move constructively because if
there isn't that conversation there's
the danger that religion will see itself
as isolated from the desires of young
people or that young people will be
frustrated and will turn to extremist
form of religious expressions and
extremism could torpedo the Arab
Awakening or this call the Arab Spring
and turn it unfortunately into a winter
so we don't want religion or tradition
to be the problem we have to make it
part of the solution there has to be
that engagement and I think that through
the mosques and through religious
traditions also job opportunities can
develop because these are networks and
we need to maximize the power both of
traditional networks and the
you networks in order to be able to
become greater than the sum of the
different parts